good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Monday
oh my God it's Monday and I would be
forlorn but I ain't because I'm sitting
down with my girl Jax hey Jax how you
doing
hey claired I'm good I do have to
acknowledge that this is our first full
week of the new year which seems
daunting I'm sure to everyone but I know
that we can make it through I just know
it
well I'm about to kind of change your
life because um we actually don't have
an episode scheduled for Friday
oh sorry yeah sorry I meant like the
world's first full week of yeah no the
new year and we still we're still
figuring out Friday but um it is the
full week back in January but it's
exciting nonetheless because even though
we should be forlorn we're not it's a
very exciting week here at the toast I'm
in Los Angeles like you probably could
tell if you're watching as a video like
oh my go ready looks like a star like
what's happened she got lip filler yeah
no I've been in L.A since Friday and I'm
definitely different
what are you thinking I know you're
really tough out in LA
I am really tough on La I'm I've been
having a nice time actually I had a
thought this morning as to why you know
I'm trying to be positive in the new
year I don't know if I've told that
about you I told you that yet I'm just
kind of like a different girl now
um here's one thing I do like about La
first of all it's like raining the
weather is forlorn which is annoying but
um but I thought you would like that I
thought you would like that together but
I'm running around town like looking
gorgeous I've curled my hair this
morning and then just to walk out of my
hotel with like a soppy mop it's not
good
it doesn't look moppy but continue on so
you're being positive I'm being positive
so here is something positive that I
noticed about Los Angeles today I was
ordering breakfast at the hotel and I
was ordering like really weird because
you know I like just eat weird [ __ ] and
the guy who was taking my order like
didn't even blink like usually when I
order my weird things I'm like no cheese
no this no that he's like okay are you
sure like you don't want the cheese
um but he was just nodding along and I
just realized like I guess everyone in
La is on some sort of weird diet like
I'm not special
yeah everyone in La is picky it's
actually weird to just say like I'll
have the chicken sandwich period nobody
says that in L.A
nobody says that in L.A and so I was
feeling like really kind of just like a
Los Angeles
I feel like whenever we go to La I love
La I think it's so exciting I think it's
so cool that the weather is so nice the
lighting you know and we're never there
for long periods of time so I never
start to hate it and I just you are
never really so into it but I feel like
you're gonna get into it this week
well can I tell you also like how coming
to La is kind of different now that
we're with dear media like to be honest
I feel like when we used to come to La
do like a week of shows there was so
much work like and we were doing
everything ourselves and now I'm just
like rolling into Deer media like look
at my microphone like I didn't set any
of this up I have this like gorgeous
Studio I have a buccal chair I didn't
even request the Google chair and I got
the buccal chair so it's kind of like
everything being done for me and I do
like that part of it I'm not gonna lie I
just want to say like you sitting there
with your legs crossed and your deer
media mic flag with like your dear media
Studio background like you're such a
dear media girly
I know I'm literally the chubby
confidential like I can just see you on
like a reels on my feed you know what
Claudia starts talking about like why
she started juicing and how it changed
her life
no and the thing about Wellness is like
once you get into wellness it's
definitely a really hard space to crack
into and then once you do become well
your life will change you'll be more um
intentional and more attentive and I
find Wellness to be already like seeping
into my my daily life here
I saw because you actually were juicing
this morning with an orange juice I did
I had well I got to the breakfast and
there was like a whole menu for juices I
was like oh my God these people are not
okay and I was like I'll have the
Tropicana orange no pulp
and
so good orange juice is a beverage that
not enough people talk about
I've been getting into it recently too
because I've had to make some freshly
squeezed OJ for Harry a few times like
whenever he's feeling a little under the
weather I'll do that and of course mommy
has to try it make sure she's not
poisoning her angel and mommy likes what
she sees it's so good I feel like
everyone drinks orange juice when
they're a kid and then they forget about
it as an adult but when you're hungover
I swear to God it's like sucking from
the teat of Mother Earth it's so
delicious
it is so delicious so now you're a
juicer you're a juice check
I'm a juice chick okay so let's also
talk about like major we need it from
the weekend I just need to I know
yesterday was a big day for football in
general but it was it felt bigger like
for us because of our pre-week recap
like we were pretty much like ESPN last
week and I had so much invested in every
game like I was looking at the Eagles
game I was looking at the Cowboys game I
was looking at the 49ers game of course
because like that's my favorite team and
then also I was looking at the Packers
game
it has nothing to do with your weekend
so I'm sure it didn't cross your mind
but like they were playing the Lions it
was it was the Sunday Night Football
game so I was just like sitting down
catching up with Zach and Carrie
Underwood came on and I was quaking the
house down it was so good I don't know
if you've watched like this year's yet
and if you've watched it in full
recently but like it's so good I had
chills
she's not talking about the game or
Carrie Underwood's performance Carrie
Underwood song
she ushered me into the game which I was
like interested in because the I like
Green Bay Packers and the Lions I like
Aaron Rodgers I do and then the Lions
had a quarterback that I had never seen
before and he was looking mighty
handsome so the thing about football
there's like a lot of Hawkeyes
so I was interested and then they were
explaining the stakes of the game that
was a high stakes game because if the
Packers win they go to the playoffs and
if the Lions win then the Seahawks go to
the playoffs which makes no [ __ ]
sense
oh okay like right sure and then the the
announcers were saying like this is a
high stakes game for both teams because
you know the Lions want to finish out
their season strong like either way
they're not going to the playoffs like
for the Packers this is make or break I
wouldn't say the stakes were high for
both teams I would say you guys are
trying to like make this an interesting
game
yeah no I wouldn't say it's the same
either
right anyways spoiler alert the Packers
lost very sad
and Seahawks I didn't know that
the Seahawks are going to the playoffs
so I have no
I'm not a Seahawks girl but I'm happy
for the Seattle toasters
first of all you should be a Seahawks
girl because of your favorite movie
Draft Day first of all
what do they have to do with it
isn't it the Seahawks doesn't the movie
no he's a coach no it's the Browns
Cleveland duh
oh
right can you see that movie again
um but here okay so here's where we come
in like to make everything about us now
that the Seahawks have made the playoffs
they're playing the 49ers this weekend
so that is the game I am going to thank
you to the Eagles for winning thus
confirming there is a 49ers game this
weekend that I can go to while I am in
La well West Coast I want to thank
everyone for sending Positive Vibes to
the Eagles I'd like to thank the Eagles
for their great work but more
importantly I'd like to thank the Giants
for doing abysmally like it wasn't even
I didn't even have a pit like I turned
the game on from the second I watched I
was like oh my God this is like the
worst team in the world playing the best
team it wasn't even a question so
grateful to the Giants grateful to
everyone and I'm grateful to myself
because I took a risk and it paid off
and there was one in the hand and there
was two in the bush and I got the two in
the bush [ __ ] and that's exciting
I'm excited for you oh so I guess that
the Packers game was relevant to our
discussion because it could you could
have been seeing Aaron Rodgers play this
weekend thing or not oh [ __ ]
yeah sorry okay well nevertheless I'm
going to the game this weekend thank God
you know there's so much like sports
energy I didn't even realize
um again not to make everything about me
but I'm here in LA and everyone's like
are you here for the game I'm like the
49ers game this weekend yeah I am like
how did you know that no tonight is
college football championship and it
happens to be in L.A I'm just wrapping
my head I'm just wrapping my head around
the AFC and the NFC and so the colleges
are gonna have to take a back seat yeah
no
um it's just like it's kind of
furthering my point
um that everything really is about us
because they had a game where you are
currently yeah just like kind of a crazy
questions
yeah when it rains it pours so who are
you rooting for TCU or Georgia
oh it's it's so hard when you don't care
you know
yeah I feel like we have more Georgia oh
it's the dogs with a d-a-w-g it's the
dogs it's the dogs yeah why does it have
to be like that why did the assistant
have to be spelled like that like no
that is the school on Long Island
no dogs
why did they spell it like that if they
didn't spell it like that I would be
like oh the dogs the Bryce and the
Strays they're not the dogs
the dogs like if I was at the game
tonight I'd be like go dogs yeah let's
get some coffee and room for the dogs I
love water
so for that reason I'm rooting for TCU
okay what does TCU stand for Tennessee
Texas Christian Texas Christian
University a question I asked last
weekend when I saw them playing so I
have the answer I would have thought it
stood for the Christian University
um I
would have thought it would be like
Tennessee Central University I wouldn't
have assumed the sea was a religion I
would have assumed it's like a region
yeah no religion
Tennessee Central didn't make it
to the playoffs and they were so
heartbroken that they didn't make it but
there's always next year Tennessee
Central University go dogs
go dogs
um so that was like a major part of my
weekend and then like another part of my
weekend was kind of like the most
probably full circle moment that's ever
happened to me
please tell us because you went to a big
soiree this weekend star studded I think
I saw you and TMZ was it Claudia your
girl TMZ TMZ
um I don't know how they knew I was
there but I was
um that's what I came to town for one of
my friends Kate it was his birthday
party and then I was like if I'm Gonna
Fly all the way out we'll make a whole
week of it so that's what we're doing
um but I flew in for his birthday party
on Saturday night and it was fabulous it
was so fun star-studded there was like
performances I saw Kelsey ballerini man
she was amazing Jeff Frost Tiffany
haddish like it was really it was
stunning
um
but most notably kind of like someone
from my former life was there and I just
I was shocked
um and I had a really
like surprising interaction with him it
was Billy Eichner now if you know he
wasn't Maverick
no it wasn't Maverick Maverick actually
had texted me that he couldn't make it
but um he said my friend Billy's going
make sure you like talk to him
um
so I saw Billy Eichner now if you've
been listening to the show for a while
if you read my book you know like a huge
part of my
my rise to fame had to do with my Cameo
on Billy on the Street when I was in
college I was on my way to a class it
was called writing the essay it was the
worst [ __ ] class if you went to NYU
you had to take it everyone knows oh my
God the worst class ever and
I was ambushed on the street by Billy
and his crew and I
there's this segment it's horrifying
it's it's not it's not it's totally fine
you're so cute you're just a college
student okay but like you had a big
distracting hat on and you played the
game and you're just being cute and I
feel like as much as you get like Say
Yes to the Dress people in your DMs like
you also get like is this you I'm Billy
on the Street
so true I get so many DMS it's like like
my thing and it was really my first time
ever being on camera like I became
obsessed I hadn't even known what the
show was it was just very exciting and
so I was at the party and I saw Billy I
can I was like oh my God Ben was like
you have to tell me you're on the street
I was like no I would like didn't want
to be like embarrassing but then the
person that Billy was with I don't know
if it was like a boyfriend I think it
was just a friend he was a really nice
guy he like had said something to me and
so I thought it was like my opportunity
to like start a combo with Billy and I
was like Billy um hi I'm Claudia and I
was actually on the street now I don't
know why I had like a preconceived
notion of how Billy Eichner would be you
know
as a person not as a celebrity but I
kind of assumed he would be like kind of
[ __ ]
I was so wrong he was so nice first of
all when I told him I was on the street
he was like giddy he was like no way he
was like actually interested in what I
was saying and he was like you were on
the street when I'm like season two
episode three I think that's what it is
um I was wearing a hat and he was like
oh my god did I make fun of you like
were you mad I'm like you read me to
Phil if you made fun of my outfit and I
deserved it and it was so funny and like
I lived for every moment of it it was my
first time on camera it like gave me
this thirst for fame I literally said
I'm like that literally started my whole
career I would not be sitting on this
chair at this party if it weren't for
our interaction so for that I'm grateful
he was so nice he actually told me he
like doesn't meet a lot of people who
have been on the street and he doesn't
meet them like maybe like someone will
come up to him like in a restaurant but
he doesn't mean on the street again
settings yeah he he was so nice it was
like such a positive interaction and it
was like it left me feeling really
um like it warmed my heart I I I really
I I kind of like love Billy Eichner now
uh so you're two for two on positive
interactions with Billy Eichner
I'm two for two on positive interactions
with Billy idler yes Jackie I am
that's so wonderful to hear you love to
hear when a celebrity is really nice and
and sweet and genuine
let me look at this whole conversation
about like Street interviewing it's like
such a thing now on Tick Tock everyone's
like always running up to people on the
street and like Billy really invented
that I feel like a lot of people forget
like he was really the first person to
do like man on the street like Ambush
comedy and he's really so impressive and
I've said you have to bring Billy on the
Street back it was iconic
yeah it really was did you have any
other positive celebrity social
interactions that you would like to
share with the class that we need to
know like who's a good person out there
I feel like everyone was pretty nice
honestly like
I saw my girly Paris uh Kelsey ballerini
she performed oh my God she is so like
breathtakingly talented everyone in the
room was shook up like by her Talent it
was it's an intimidating room you know
lots of celebs Hollywood Peeps and she's
you know just a girl from Nashville and
she just got up there with her guitar
and sang two songs she's saying if you
go down I'm going down too from her new
album and then she sang Peter Pan Peter
Pan
yeah which was perfect song for a
birthday song Next Level it was really
just a great event a lot of people were
messaging me asking if I saw Britney
Spears who was at the party and when I
tell you when I woke up the next morning
and found out she was there I was
shocked because I didn't even see her
now that's not that crazy because I'm
like always you know thinking about me
and like looking at me in the mirror and
like just minding my business drinking a
lot so I didn't see her
um but I heard she was there
that's exciting
yeah you were in the present
we're in the presence of greatness
um tell me about your weekend Jax make a
chili my weekend I did not make a chili
and that's like hurtful that you would
suggest that after everything I've been
through
after I was attacked for my chili yeah
yeah it's like used as a weapon against
me even though people are still making
chilies in solidarity and I see all your
tags and it's really beautiful how we've
all come together but my weekend was
great it was a little bit different from
your weekend just this is a smidgeiest
bit of difference
um I was just home with my boys all my
boys we hung out with the Shapiro's and
we had some good times you know I did
not go car shopping
I did not go car shopping it actually I
think it might be easier for me to go on
a weekday especially now that our
schedule's a little different so
hopefully this week I will go and now
I'm leaning towards Volvo like last week
I was leaning towards Lexus but a lot of
people have waited one I think the
biggest factor in bringing me towards
Volvo is Edward Cullen like when you
think about what a car represents and
what kind of vibe you're putting forth
like I want to be putting forth Cullen
Vibes and
that really like and it's if it's good
enough for Edward and you know that like
Stephanie Meyer research and research
what car she should choose for Edward
and she came up with that like why do I
need to do more research
when I was
um when we were talking last week about
like car associations like where you
associate different brands with I
totally forgotten that the Volvos
weren't exclusively Cullen car and that
changes everything it really changes
everything so I'm fully on board I'm in
support as long as I get like my seat
heater in the passenger seat you know
not lights like lots of leg room have
apple carplay all that stuff I'm okay
with that I'm great I think that's
wonderful
yeah so I think that's where I'll be
headed first and it's like for the
Collins and for The Mamas for real so I
feel like that's gonna be what's best
for me so hopefully I'll have an update
about that this week but other than that
just relaxing weekend at home not much
report
and um like kind of like discussing not
much to report when you literally live
in the same house as my
my king roll day what's new with him
well he got a car this weekend so that
was exciting for him
Harry got a car before his mom
he did he has one of his like little toy
cars um we put it together this weekend
he was driving around his new Whip and
he was obsessed like obsessed Beyond me
played with it all weekend he never got
tired of it we never got tired of seeing
him in it it was so much fun
I feel like I could see Harry just like
picking up [ __ ] in that car [ __ ]
being me
yeah no it's a convertible and like it
plays music and he was just like driving
in it and it literally looks like he was
in Miami like cruising down
the side of the beach
um in Miami [ __ ] that's literally Harry
like
imagine Harry at the club and then he
picked like he picked up Bruno and the
two of them were just like cruising for
girls and it was really sweet
two of them picking up [ __ ]
yeah they wouldn't refer to women that
way but
they were looking for nice young ladies
no I think that Harry would never refer
to like a woman as a [ __ ] but I could
see Bruno [ __ ] up some [ __ ] you
know
only what anolia on her worst day
she needs it
don't tell snitch even though everyone's
about to DM her they said nolia needs to
be [ __ ] up
all right well we have a fabulous show
today we've got stories we've got heart
we've got Charisma and I feel like
there's no better time than the present
to dive into the Fast Five what do you
think Jax I think it is time without
further did it do about sports which we
just like can't stop talking about these
days like okay sorry we don't have any
sports stories but you know us we'll
find a way to make it about sports
and then in turn find a way to make it
about us because Sports is about us
Sports is life
Sports is life bro
it is time for the past five stories
that you need to know
and today's episode I would be remiss I
would be devastated I might even be
heartbroken if I didn't let you know
that today's episode was brought to you
by Squarespace Squarespace is a fabulous
tool to use if you have a
side hustle an e-commerce business from
websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics Squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business so
whatever your product is whatever you're
selling whether you have like a side
hustle you want to start selling stuff
online Squarespace is a great place to
start if you don't have a ton of like
web design experience because like who
does but I feel like everyone needs a
website whether you're trying to make
yourself a portfolio are you an artist a
photographer there are so many different
features on Squarespace that'll really
benefit your business
um what I really like is their ability
to
um sync up your social media so you can
feed all your social media content to
your website it's a great way to get
your name out there your business and
then when people want to shop you've got
like this gorgeous website that looks
like you paid a lot of money for like a
fancy designer and you just did it all
yourself on Squarespace
um we also have obviously a code for you
guys because we support business owners
it's squarespace.com toast you'll get a
free trial and then when you're ready to
launch your website use our code toast
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or your domain so it can be
really tough to like get your domain
whatever your website is whether it's
like you know seashells by Sally they
can help you find the right domain
that's like super cute and easy to find
and easily searchable
um Squarespace really is the One-Stop
shop for e-commerce
um and again they make it super easy you
don't need to be like a tech wizard to
get your site up and running they'll
make it look really fancy and look like
it took a lot of money and time but
spoiler alert it did not so many great
features so many tools to get your
business off the ground like e-commerce
templates inventory management a simple
checkout process secure online payments
whatever it is that you're selling
Squarespace is merchandise and features
to make your products look best online
so again that's squarespace.com toast
for a free trial when you're ready to
launch use your RR hour offer code toast
to save that 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain squarespace.com
toast and then once you're ready to
launch that offer code is toast again
you can connect with your audience
generate Revenue
um you can make members only content
whatever it is that you're selling
online you know you have a podcast you
need a website you know gives an
alcoholic beverage you need a website
squarespace.com toast is the One Stop
Shop for that and today's episode is
also brought to you by honey it's easy
to save when you're shopping on your
iPhone or your computer with honey so
Jackie and I've been honey customers
long before they uh were brought on as a
sponsor it is the greatest most genius
thing it is a free to download browser
extension it's free to download when you
use our link and then this is how it
works you're shopping you're having a
good time enjoying your life shopping
for makeup clothes uh I've used it on
electronics I've used it on food and
once you're ready to check out honey
will just pop up and be like hey girl
click this button and you can save some
money they will scour the internet for
different promo codes and they will get
you the best possible price I've used it
for years on my computer and now they
have a safari on your phone browser
extension so if you shop online you know
when you're at class or like you're
supposed to be working
um you can also do it on your phone now
which is really stunning so if they find
a work working coupon you will just
watch the prices drop they search the
internet for all the coupons that it can
find and now it just just doesn't just
work on desktop it works on your iPhone
too activated on Safari on your phone
and then you'll just save on the go
takes a few seconds for honey to search
it's so easy I used at revolve at
Bloomingdale's literally everywhere if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out by getting it
you're doing yourself a solid it is free
to download when you use our link and
then you're saving money they've saved
their customers millions and millions of
dollars over the years it is the
greatest browser extension
um it's PayPal honey you can get it for
free when you go to joinhoney.com toast
that's join honey
j-o-i-n-h-o-n-e-y.com slash toast you
can get the browser extension for free
at joinhoney.com turst
toast actually but also curse we should
we should work on getting that to be
like an alternate promo code for some of
our listeners who just speak the way
that we do who get it but the real link
is joinhoney.com t-o-a-s-t thank you
honey and Squarespace for sponsoring
today's episode which is sure to be a
good time because there's some good
stories now I meant to ask you this
before we dove into the podcast but now
it's too late like because I was also
looking this morning for stories and
it's impossible to open your phone
without being inundated by something
Prince Harry has said are we discussing
any Prince Harry
um nonsense today no like I can take a
[ __ ] hint with you yelling at me
saying you don't want to talk about it
so I I kind of read between the lines on
that and I didn't choose any more Megan
and Harry stories no I'm glad because
like I'm so subtle I didn't know if you
had like picked up on that
yeah no I I'm like pretty with it I
would say like I can really like
understand people and I felt like that's
what you were trying to tell me but you
couldn't find the words no and you
definitely understand people really well
but you really understand me and I'm not
the type of person to just like kind of
say how I feel outright I'll just kind
of skirt around the issue and what I
love about you and just working with you
as my sister was like you know you you
get me
yeah because you really are like passive
aggressive and you just like want people
to read your mind and that's what I do
though I'm I'm your personal mind reader
so true so true so true so no we will
not be discussing any of the craziness
that's going on I think I need to start
a new podcast
um literally because there's so much
going on like if if this were a
one-woman show like we would be talking
about it every single day because the
craziness continues to unfold like he
doesn't stop sitting down for interviews
but we won't be talking about any of
that instead we'll be talking about the
other big news from the weekend
which is a real housewives of Salt Lake
City Sergeant Shaw has been sentenced to
six and a half years in prison for fraud
and the Real Housewives of Salt Lake
City Star Jen Shaw has been sentenced to
six and a half years or 78 months in
prison for wire fraud her attorney told
page six on Friday that quote Jen is
deeply regrets the mistakes that she has
made and is profoundly sorry to the
people she has hurt Jen has faith in our
justice system understands that anyone
who breaks the law will be punished and
accepts this sentence as just Jen will
pay her debt to society and when she's a
free woman again she vows to pay her
debt to the victims harmed by her
mistakes
okay I was really shocked of course on
Friday's episode we were waiting with
baited breath refreshing our phones
every 10 seconds waiting to see what the
verdict would be and then it came out
literally 20 minutes after our episode
dropped but I'm actually glad that it
did because I had like a lot of
questions
um about it and I was able to read up on
her sentencing and I said before like I
know their crimes were not similar but I
am comparing this almost just
instinctively to the Chrisley case
because the Chrisleys were sentenced to
12 years in prison like a month ago so
it's just in my mind like reality star
you know Finance crimes and I found her
sentence to
be so much lower especially because when
that big thing came out when she was
arrested the Attorney General she was
facing up to 30 years so I just six and
a half years is obviously a long time to
like not see your family and stay in
prison but like based on what she was up
against it doesn't it feels like she she
got a good sentence
yeah I don't know why I thought she was
going away for like 50 years right
because that's how they made it seem
when the whole thing happened like the
FBI attorney general U.S federal
government like it was Dev and I think
her taking or her uh the plea deal and
and
what's the word like admitting guilt
pleading pleading guilty
um was huge for her and so that's what I
learned when I was just like looking
into the Chrisley thing is like the
Chrisleys went to trial they like wasted
like when you waste the government's
like time and energy and money when you
are guilty I think you get a harsher
sentence than like just admitting your
guilt saving the court the judge the
jurors time and they'll give you
leniency for that so she at first wasn't
pleading guilty she was going to go to
trial and then a few weeks ago or months
ago I forgot how long she said yeah I
did that [ __ ] and that was smart because
that's how she ended up with six and a
half years I don't know what she would
have gotten if they had went through the
whole trial
yeah or she could have been proven
innocent if she felt that she was
innocent that's why you go to trial if
you think you're innocent yeah well I
guess she wasn't
so it's not that I mean six and a half
years is a long time but like
I feel like by the time she comes out
like Housewives will still be on the air
and like she'll be back I just thought
that like she would get a sentence that
was so long that like whenever she comes
back like there's no more Housewives
like we've moved on like you and I will
be 50 years old the aliens have
inhabited the planet I know what you
mean but no and then dumwa posted
something which of course you take with
a grain of salt that real houses of Salt
Lake City is going on Hiatus like
they're kind of gonna like to sleep
clean with the cast it's really bad the
show and they're gonna take some time
off like maybe pull a Dallas not cancel
it but like it won't be around for a
while and so it kind of makes sense like
maybe they take off like six and a half
years like I feel like at this point
Dallas has been off the air for at least
three years and it doesn't feel like
it's been that long so another three and
then if it were to come back in another
three that would be like Salt Lake City
waiting for Jen it's not inconceivable
no it's not unconceivable especially I
don't know how it works with federal
crimes but like people get sentenced to
like 10 years and they get out in six
for good behavior yeah she I don't know
I don't know if with federal crimes like
you I think you have to serve I think I
read somewhere like 80 of your sentence
so I don't know what the minimum amount
of time that she could serve is but yeah
and I just I really feel like even if
the dumwa thing's not true but like the
way the Real Housewives of Salt Lake
City were given this like gem like they
they
they could have made these last two
seasons into like historically Good
Seasons but the way that like this gen
thing happened which is like the
craziest most Global historic news in
Housewives history and then they're
going on Hiatus because they flopped so
much like it's so crazy to me I feel
like I know I can't stop talking about
it but it should have been
huge and it wasn't
yeah well they weren't equipped and all
of this happened after the first season
of Housewives so maybe they just like
were not up to the challenge they
weren't seasoned enough Housewives yeah
they didn't know how to exactly how to
do the job
that's definitely what it was
um and so when I compare it again like
to the Chrisleys first of all it's
double the time they're going away for
12 years the Chrisleys are older and
it's like by the time you get out like
six years is a long time but like it's
not like you'll you know you see Mr kids
growing up like
it does feel like a very lenient
sentence it really does
yes
it does in in the grand scheme of what
could have been
and in the grand scheme of what she did
and it's like the Chrisley's defrauded
like the government and Banks and and
even though I will say what what I also
read and discovered was like they
weren't you know defrauding Citibank it
was these like smaller Southern like Mom
and Pop Banks still like big
institutions but not you know Chase
so it's still [ __ ] up for sure but I
think what gen shot did is like 45 times
worse yes I would agree
so this Saga which like I feel like it
all happened kind of quickly like when
she from when she got arrested like when
we read about it it doesn't feel like
it's been that long even though it has
been what like two years two three years
maybe
it does feel like the whole process was
pretty quick
yeah in hindsight but not what it felt
like for so long it was like We'll see
and it's till proven guilty now she's
pled guilty what's the sentence though
like now it's really over for now until
whenever she starts serving and then I'm
sure we'll see her on real house I was
in six and a half years
yeah no and I also probably would assume
it didn't feel like it went by really
quickly for General
but also I think that
do you want it to go by quickly or do
you want to drag it out because then you
get more time before you have to go
yeah but then you're also just delaying
the inevitable like yeah you want to
push back what you go into prison but
you're gonna have to go anyway so you
might as well just get it over with yes
maybe at this stage now that she knows
what her sentence is but like along the
way you can kind of delude yourself into
think like well maybe I'll be proven
innocent okay well maybe the sentence
won't be that long like I think now that
she's gotten her sentence I think a lot
of people do want to go and start it as
soon as possible but over the last few
years
dragging out might not have been like
the worst thing for her and it bought
her more time on the show
that's true and like more opportunities
to make money because I'm sure she also
owes some sort of restitution to her
victims yes she should
as she should
um and I don't know what federal prison
is like I don't know what you know is it
I I think I I read she was going away to
a minimum security prison in Texas yeah
she's going to Texas
um I don't know if our federal prisons
like worse better is it like you know
the Lori Lachlan type of prison like is
it like chill is it Camp I don't know I
don't know either
wishing her best you know wishing her
the best wishing her victims you know a
speedy recovery because
it's so [ __ ] up like it's beyond yeah
yeah
okay you ready for our next story
yeah yeah I am a little nepo baby news
because Haley Bieber is weighing in on
the discourse with a fashion statement
Haley Bieber is not afraid to make a
fashion statement the Rhodes kid founder
stepped out in LA on Friday and was
photographed in a parking garage wearing
a baby tee with the words nepo baby
printed across the front she obviously
like styled it in her classic way jeans
see some stomper boots little purse
little bag and people are quaking she's
really embracing the controversy some
celebrities like Gwyneth commented being
like I'm gonna need a bunch of these
shirts and I'm kind of loving her
approach to this
I agree I think a lot of people thought
this was like a major serve for her like
like because on the nepo baby topic like
we want to hear from everyone except the
nepo babies and like I think a lot of
nepo babies during the the discourse
have come on and like responded and just
kind of defended themselves being like
I've worked really hard and there's no
doubting that but like shut up like it's
just kind of like
it's not it's not illegal to be a Nepal
baby but like don't talk like seriously
shut up and Haley Bieber just kind of
owning it with the t-shirt is so like
iconically iconic and it's just it's
exactly what we needed because like we
don't want to hear from them like yep
I'm an apple baby period end of story
and that's what she did and like Gwyneth
getting involved in the commenting it's
a it's this was such a sleigh it was a
sleigh and a half it was and it shows
like you know a level of
self-deprecation like humor and
personality which I think it underscores
the point that nepo babies are trying to
make when they do try and speak about it
which is like I have more to offer than
just my Birthright and also the fact
that she is
very famous for being very stylish and
then she's like taking the the title and
putting her spin on it I think it's
really a beautiful moment in celebrity
nepo babies taking back their power
I completely agree like and honestly I
didn't see hilly Bieber as like
someone who would do this I feel like
she like avoids all certain types of
like controversy or conflict or even
just like you know sticky subjects so I
feel like she would have just let this
conversation happen around her she's
obviously an echo baby she's not going
to speak out on it she's not going to
defend herself she's not gonna defend
Nepal baby she's not going to attack
nipple babies I feel like she's very
conflict diverse so this is kind of like
a big deal yeah I agree I didn't see
this for her but also I feel like when
we talk about the biggest nepo babies
like who comes to mind weirdly I don't
think we've talked about her once even
though of course she is an EPO baby
period but like when we were going back
and forth with names I feel like there
are some that get the most credit for
attention attention and backlash
probably and I feel like she inserted
herself into this conversation when
really she wasn't getting that much heat
over it actually I'm not in her DMS and
in her comments like I don't know what
people say to her but and it's just like
I could say did Jelena stands don't ever
say anything about Haley but like she
experiences it differently but I do feel
like she's not even top 10 of who you
think of when you think of NEPA lady
that's true and I think it's mostly
because like her dad's kind of like a
flop like he's
certainly like a an actor but when you
think of the Baldwin family you think of
Alec so I think part of it has to do
with her being like the niece of Alec
and her dad like definitely being like
an accomplished actor but not like a big
Hollywood wheeling and dealing power
like he's not
that famous so I think mostly it's
because of that
yeah and also
I don't know maybe it's also because
like at this point she's also married to
someone who's so big so like what's the
word for that person
that's an amazing call
married like NEPA wife
I feel like if everything in the world
made sense like Haley Bieber would have
been Alec Baldwin's daughter and Ireland
Baldwin would have been Stephen
Baldwin's daughter do you know what I
mean
I do but
I do and I don't yeah I know what you
mean on this on the surface level
on a Surface lyrics level yes which we
love lyrics that go beyond the surface
sometimes but sometimes we just need to
stay on the surface and I know we have
so many new listeners and it's so
annoying when like we always reference
old inside jokes but like I'm genuinely
begging you to go find the reference of
surface lyrics it is probably one of my
favorite stories ever told just tell it
just tell you you don't tell it often
you've never you haven't told it more
than one so just tell it I was in
Nashville and maybe like 2018. Ben and I
used to have like this big partnership
with diagio Spirits
um so we would travel mostly with like
uh Captain Morgan and some of their like
you know millennially Brands
um we became really friendly with the
people who worked there like I still am
friends with a lot of them and they knew
we loved country music and Nashville and
so I had never been to Nashville and
they were planning a it wasn't an
influencer trip it was a um
like taste makers blog food
writers like
they were going to the George Dickel
distillery in Nashville it was going to
be it wasn't an influencer trip it was
just like this press trip and they were
like if you guys want to come like you
can come like it's not like an influence
or a fancy trip like you've never been
to Nashville and like you love country
music and Dustin Lynch was performing so
we just like hopped along like on this
influence on this writer's Trip full of
like writers from around the world who
write about like liquor like cocktails
and and food and so it was a kind of
like an older kind of like weird crowd
but like me and Ben were just happy to
be there and we were doing like a day of
activities we went to The Distillery and
then we went to like uh
what's it called Hattie B's Hot Chicken
so we're in this car with a bunch of
like fancy older writers and we're
talking about Nashville and it's being
Ben's first time and how I was I said
I'm like I love country music they're
like really that's so weird you're from
New York yada yada and we were talking
about why we like country music and Ben
like
answered for us which is just weird
because like Ben doesn't even like
country music as much as I do and he
goes he gave like probably the weirdest
answer
um anyone could ever give as to why they
like country music Ben goes
yeah no it's just like if you listen to
the lyrics they're so not like surface
lyrics
and the car was just silent like nobody
responded because one like what the [ __ ]
does that even mean and two like uh okay
surface lyrics like what uh when we got
out of the car I roasted Ben to [ __ ]
filth I'm like what the [ __ ] did you
just say he was like so embarrassed like
nobody answered him nobody even made a
sound like the conversation died at that
moment nobody said anything until we got
out of the car and now I can't say the
word surface whether I'm talking about
like a Surface Cleaner or you know on
the surface it has to be surface lyrics
and he said lyrics Not lyrics
which is just another
long
yeah wrong so that's where surface
lyrics comes from in case you're
wondering yeah and that's why on the
surface lyrics it would seem like a heli
Bieber should be Alex child oh speaking
of Alec Baldwin I'm sure this isn't a
story because it's moronic but I wanted
to share did you see Alec Baldwin is
being mocked endlessly for his most
recent Instagram post
I saw he was being mocked something to
do with a million followers
so he made this video like begging his
followers to follow ilaria or as I like
to call her Hillary from Boston
um he was begging people to follow her
uh her birthday's coming up and he wants
to help her reach a million followers
and it was just like kind of like
something I would do you know and like
why is Alec Baldwin this like major
actor you know doing this it was kind of
beneath him and he got roasted and
that's just what happened with it that's
what happens this weekend when you [ __ ]
around you find out you know that
happens when you act out and like act
embarrassing on social media
yeah especially when you're Alec Baldwin
like you've just got like bigger things
you should be worried about no
especially when you're Alec Baldwin who
like in you know recent years has really
become like not
like not taken seriously I think not
people's favorite the Hillary of it all
had a lot to do with it and I think him
urging people like begging for followers
and then it being his scam artist Anna
Del V wife it just wasn't it wasn't the
vibe right I would say also the shooting
has a lot to do with it I didn't want to
bring that up but yeah
why the [ __ ] you have to bring that up
by the way you have to get on tick tock
I'm on Tick Tock say I talk to you every
day
so true I'm kind of like the
personification of tick tock you really
are why the [ __ ] you have to bring that
up
uh I don't know because it's Jermaine to
Alec Baldwin it is Jermaine and it's
it's still in my mind one of the
craziest things that's probably ever
happened in the history of Hollywood
um
and it's so sad it is so sad Like This
Woman This mom this young talented woman
died it is so sad that's why like I
that's honestly why I didn't bring it up
because like at the end of the day it's
like this crazy Alec Baldwin thing but
it's also like literally somebody died
so it it to me it's one of the craziest
and saddest things that's ever happened
yeah but I think it would be like sadder
to not forget about it and just kind of
like let it pass without just like
you're right constantly being like
remembering her
okay
are you ready for our next story
Switching gears in a major way to a
little beauty business news oh my God
yes I'm so glad you chose this story
morphe Cosmetics is closing all U.S
retail stores employees say they were
left in the dark for weeks morphe
cosmetics and makeup brand one
synonymous with YouTube beauty culture
confirmed Thursday it was shutting down
all its U.S stores
a move that shocked its employees
outrage customers and left some experts
questioning the Brand's future well it
sounds like the future is Bleak if they
just closed down all their stores but
okay the news comes after a handful
there's actually nothing questionable
about it I don't have a question I don't
have questions about the future I have
questions about the past right like how
the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] you have to bring
that up no like how did they fumble the
ball so big well I think it's more of a
statement on YouTube beauty culture than
it is on morphe because morphe was just
an extension of YouTube beauty culture I
feel like they didn't expand right now I
mean based on what you taught me like
Beauty culture is really popping off on
Tick Tock so like Michaela should have a
line at morphe Alex Earl based on and
this is just me you know getting my
information from my favorite trusted
news source mclartia Lotteria
and that's just how you know like I
genuinely um like I'm right about
everything because you're 100 right I
think it's I think a lot of people are
shocked because beauty is is a space
that's so impacted by influencer culture
so a brand that like Dove head first
into influencer culture failing like
this it's like well is this a statement
on influencer you know like the value of
influencers and no actually I think
maybe like two years ago when Tick Tock
started popping off is really when
morphe started dying off in my mind like
they were so in YouTube culture and that
was great for a while but you're right
like the epicenter of beauty trends is
Tick Tock right now and I feel like when
they launched morphe 2 they made Charlie
and Dixie the face and then that was the
last thing they ever did with Tick Tock
and I don't know why they didn't lean in
more you're right like Michaela and even
so many of those
big YouTube people are now huge on Tick
Tock and I think they value it just as
much as they value their YouTube
channels like nikkietutorials is huge
Jackie Aina like I don't know why morphe
didn't keep up that energy past the
YouTube era yeah I mean maybe there's
more you know behind the scenes where
it's like they couldn't afford to invest
more in like these new people and I
understand like going so hard on
influencer culture and I don't think
that that's a bad business model but if
you're going to do that you have to be
aware of like influencer culture changes
every five minutes and you have to
change with that and like I wouldn't
give every influencer like their whole
ass line like I'd be like let's clap on
a product like oh Alex Earl's always
wearing the white eyeliner like let's do
Alex earlier I didn't know that because
I
don't know I really don't well I follow
Alex Earl on Instagram so I get bits and
pieces of Miss Earl what do you think
about her she's kind of everything of
the sort she's really fabulous she's
just like you could tell she and I know
from you that she's just like in college
and being a college girl you can tell
from so much of her content she's just
like going to party she'd like post with
her friends and then she also does like
influency type things but it does feel
like following someone who's in college
who's just like famous at their college
which is fun yeah it must be exciting
for her to like go to college parties
with just like people she's hung out
with for the last four years but then
also I go to La and meet Selena Gomez
like really best Hannah Montana
yeah and also to like post from like her
regular life stuff and it must be so fun
for her friends to be like oh my God
this is crazy no I feel like when we
like years ago had Danielle carolan on
the toast you spoke to her a lot about
that because she was in college at the
time and she was like blowing up on
YouTube and it's like so cool to have
these like two different like worlds but
then be like kind of famous in college
yeah famous in college so it also is
important to note about the more if you
think they're closing their retail
stores I think they're still going to be
they still are a beauty brand so I think
also this is probably just a statement
on retail in general I think there's a
lot of successful makeup brands and they
don't have their own stores I would
argue that most most don't
yes but I actually think that retail is
pretty important for beauty like I think
for a lot of other categories you can
pretty much write out retail completely
but like to go to the store and to see
the colors in person and like to swab it
like that's something that you can't get
online and so I don't think that like
retail needs to be dead for the beauty
industry in general like I do think that
I sometimes order my makeup online but I
really do prefer to go to the store yeah
of course but like if you're going to go
to a makeup store you're going to go to
Sephora that sells 50 brands are you
gonna go to morphe that sells one brand
well it depends what you're looking for
and like if I'm saying these individual
Brands having their own stores like
that's really difficult to maintain I
feel like the only brand who continues
to do that and is still
killing it is mac and that's because Mac
is like the original Beauty brand ever
like the first one ever made
but that that's not why they're still
killing it
then why why do you think they are I
have no idea what like I don't really
shop there I don't know what their
secret sauce is but just because they
were the first honestly sometimes when
you're the first you're also the last
like yeah but like they're they're so at
the epicenter of like makeup artist like
I feel like if you want to be a makeup
artist you have to have worked at Mac
it's like this really prestigious which
is so crazy because I actually don't
think I use a single Mac product at one
time yes and I think for a long time
that's sustain their business but like
why they are still in business today I
would love to know because the whole
industry has changed they're not really
like tick-tocky and but sometimes just
like quality is quality like I don't
care what's going on on Tick Tock like I
want good [ __ ] and I know that Mac has
it
that's it like they have major like
quality
major quality period I'm gonna end the
sentence they have the major quality
major quality that's how we feel about a
lot of the brands that I use because I
don't really switch up my makeup
ever but like some of my favorite
cosmetic brands like Nars they're not
doing anything crazy they're not going
viral they're just major questions
actually
they they do have like some some
virality what do they go viral for I
mean their most recent launch of
foundation I'm actually wearing it today
Nars light reflecting Foundation is like
a tick tock top five
um
product it is one of the best
foundations like okay so I
I've been using their foundation for
like four or five years
yeah and the the old one the version
that you use the taller skinnier bottle
is also like a staple but the new one
like Michaela negara is on this journey
to finding her wedding foundation and
she's like narrowed it down to five of
the best and the Nars light reflecting
Foundation is on that list I also have
the light reflecting Foundation because
I'm on their PR list so I use that one
when I can't find my tall skinny one and
I love it too I love it I think they're
both really great that's also the other
thing about this morphe situation is
like in the last few years there's a
million new brands some pop off some
don't and there really isn't space for
an unlimited amount of brands in the
beauty space so it's like Fenty and uh
Selena Gomez like all these celebrity
ones taking off and then these ones
going viral but creating huge Beauty
Brands Jones Road Bobby Brown like
there's so many Brands like eventually
we were just reported recently um Becca
is going out bite beauty is going out
like there's not enough space for
everyone So eventually somebody and so
just morphe being one to like
scale down is a really big deal because
they were so big
yeah they were so big so in addition to
scaling down a handful of the company's
employees took to tick tock over the
holidays to call out the company's lack
of transparency during the layoffs with
many using the hashtag hashtag Justice
for morphe retail employees viewers
quickly responded in support blasting
the brand for allegedly leaving it to
poison the dark while stores ran out of
inventory some beauty experts said the
news was not surprising given that the
company had reportedly experienced years
of Financial and legal troubles and
reputational damage the Brand's
treatment of employees during the
shutdown could further hurt its
reputation among gen Z consumers who
have already demonstrated their aversion
towards morphe
no like I mean I don't keep like I'm
into Beauty but I'm not that into beauty
that I was like keeping up with morphe
sales and and and Scandals but um if you
are then you might have heard that I
hadn't heard any of that like as far as
I knew it definitely just felt like from
a consumer POV like and someone who's on
Tick Tock and watches a lot of social
media like morphe was just becoming
irrelevant yeah because I think that the
people that they invested in were less
relevant than not only less relevant
than they once were but also like
controversial now like James Charles and
Jeffree Star and like that's really I
think where they probably put the most
money into and so then there's like not
really money for other things
yeah but what's so crazy is like no
matter how controversial that James
Charles palette with morphe I think is
the best-selling eyeshadow palette in
the history of beauty like it it was the
biggest baddest thing
yeah no and and it was but it's like
what'd you do today you know and that's
what's sad like you can't just like
cruise on that one palette no and that's
what like if you're gonna get into any
space that's like even like what we do
like influencing or podcasting it's so
you can't be stagnant for one you can't
rest you cannot you can rest so and
beauty is like now weirdly like such a
tech influence space that you have to
keep doing be doing the most it's
exhausting like the amount of launches
the amount of companies the amount of
new products like
and like also with beauty like everybody
wants everyone to invent like the newest
thing it's not just about like pronounce
cool colors of existing products but
it's like did you transform my face
today with one lip gloss or no right
like is this lip gloss also a blush that
changes the pH of your face
then I don't want it exactly it's like
it's very competitive which is good for
the consumer because I feel like there's
so much good makeup out there no matter
what like your price range is your
budget is whatever you're looking for I
feel like the crazy boom in in the
makeup industry has actually been great
for us like I feel like I love
all the makeup I've you know gotten over
the last few years and like I now use
like my core products I feel like makeup
is like kind of like killing it yeah no
for sure it is it's definitely a fun
industry for to be in I'm not speaking
from experience I'm just saying like it
seems like a fun uh place it also has
really high margins so there's a lot of
room for big success but you've got to
constantly be innovating not just like
with colors like with products like you
literally need to be an inventor so good
luck to you on that I personally I like
the classics I don't really get caught
up in these trends like everyone's
always like do an updated makeup
tutorial and it's like I totally could
I'd be happy to but it's the same one
that you saw four years ago
um it's tried and true and you you
experienced it when I did your makeup
because if you do Tick Tock makeup but I
do like back in the day Contour makeup
like just like angles and you were like
yeah there's something to this 100 like
it's a staple for a reason
so don't feel bad if you're not caught
up with these Trends because I'm not
I know some people might be feeling bad
I know like they're probably listening
to this podcast crying like don't cry
it's okay
it's okay if you don't have a lipstick
that's also a blush that changes the pH
of your skin
I mean it's it's fine it's not okay
okay totally well are you ready for our
next story
if it's the next story that's brought to
you by framebridge is that perchance the
story that you have it is a tis
framebridge the Custom Framing company
is the perfect way to refresh your space
for the New Year by Framing everything
that matters to you and that's because
they can frame Bridge just about
anything whether it's Game Day Jerseys
selfies your anniversary dinner menu
artwork or your favorite movie poster
here's how it works go to
framebridge.com upload your digital
photo if you have a physical photo that
you'd like to frame like a poster they
will send you complimentary packaging to
safely mail it into the factory you can
preview your piece online in dozens of
frame styles and choose your favorite
the experts at framebridge will custom
frame your piece and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang instead of the hundreds of
dollars you'd pay at a framing store
their prices start at just 39 order
online at framebridge.com or stop by a
framebridge store near you to work with
the designer in person Jackie I know you
have this gorgeous self-portrait an
iPhone photo that really looks kind of
like an Andy Warhol that you framed in
your closet correct can you tell me
about that process the process was so
wonderful you can pick the photo off
your phone if you did happen to take
just like a gorgeous picture on your
phone which most of us do because our
iPhones our camera quality is better
than like most cameras and it just
uploaded it to framebridge chose you
know my mat my frame size frame color et
cetera Etc and then it came shipped
directly to me looking so gorgeous and
ready to hang so I actually need some
more art around my house and I need like
really big picture art and it's like I
have so many great
pictures that Zach and I have taken over
the years of not just ourselves but you
know settings that we've been in and one
it's beautiful and two it's a great
memory so I would highly recommend free
image if you're decorating if you're
looking for a gift for someone if you
just like want to treat yourself to a
glamorous self-portrait in your bedroom
or bathroom like you really can't go
wrong
get started today and frame your photos
or give someone the perfect gift go to
framebridge.com and place your order
today that's
framebridge.com please add order today
girlies all right Jack thank you our
next story is a little Bravo News Real
Housewives of Potomac star Ashley Darby
confirms that she and summer house Alama
Luke goldbergson have split it's a wrap
on the romance for Ashley and Luke the
Bravo Liberties have called it quits
after lasting less than three months of
dating Ashley confirmed on Sunday
night's episode of Watch What Happens
Live she said quote Luke and I are not
romantically involved anymore she went
on to explain that her ongoing divorce
with her estranged husband Michael Darby
is to blame for their split she said
quote it was my situation with Michael
that affected Luke and I she said that
she and Michael are having a really hard
time with co-parenting and separating
she said really my life is very
complicated as you guys can imagine I'm
going through a very difficult situation
that doesn't mean Luke didn't try his
best though she said quote Luke was a
trooper believe me he went through some
things she also said that she met his
family during their time together and
that quote they were amazing I fell in
love with them so great she said she
isn't worried about jumping back into
the dating pool again I'm newly single
this is my first relationship after and
it's nice to be reminded that I am a
girl and that I love to love and I love
to be loved give me all the love so I
would say this is the definition of like
a rebound relationship that's totally
positive didn't work out I don't think
anyone expected these two to get married
but like gave Ashley her groove back and
like showed her what she deserves and I
think that's a beautiful storybook
ending no like as much as this was like
a cute couple I'm not surprised and I'm
not sad I feel like actually we got out
of these too like more than I thought we
were gonna get I really thought it was
like a Bravo con like drunk hook up and
like they were living for like the
social media attention I didn't think it
was going to be anything real and the
fact that she actually experienced like
a nice three-month relationship with
somebody who probably treated her so
much better and so different than her
previous relationship and like showed
her like the possibilities of what's out
there I feel like she's probably really
grateful to Luke I'm grateful to Luke
and like you know what it's okay okay I
feel like it's okay
I feel like it's okay too every day of
these three months was a blessing for
all of us and more than we deserved and
I
I think this is all good and
you know some people come into your life
for a reason or a season no it's so true
and I feel like I follow Ashley Darby on
Tick Tock and she's like really get like
feeling herself like getting her group
back I think she's like you know reached
this just like kind of peaceful place
she's always dancing she's always with
her friends and so I feel like Luke
probably helped get her there a little
bit like showing showing her you know it
doesn't always have to be that hard in a
relationship and I feel like he probably
kept it like simple and fun and he's
young and it was good it was a fun
moment for the Bravo fans a little
crossover and it was good it was good
it's enough
it was good I don't really know Luke
that well because I didn't watch summer
house when he was on I only know him
from like that one season of winter
house where he was just like kind of
like being a lumberjack and while like
I'm really happy for Ashley RB and I
feel like the narrative here is like
good for Ashley this was good for Ashley
like you know he did it was everything
she needed him to be but it's like what
about Luke like when's it gonna be
Luke's turn he seems like a good guy you
know when he's not just like here to be
like
used
[Music]
I know you mean yeah yeah yeah no I know
you're saying it's like yeah thanks Luke
but it's like what about Luke like when
is it Luke's turn I totally hear what
you're saying I feel like
um I watched him on summer house he like
went through a little bit of a rough
patch like kind of like giving fuckboy
energy but at the end of the day he's
like a nice guy he's not a bad guy
um he's not like Austin level I just
think maybe he was like bad at
communicating and got himself like a
little bit of a bad reputation because
like he literally couldn't talk to
people
um I think I think Luke gets on fine
honestly I think Luke is taking care of
Luke for real do you think it will be
Luke's turn soon no
because you know what like this is just
a fact of life like some people are main
characters and some people are not
and you don't think he's the main
character
no he gives very like supportive energy
like supportive character energy
wow okay that's like really really harsh
is it
I think it's harsh yeah I think
everybody if you're not the main
character of your own life like I didn't
tell you that what are you doing no but
it's like character of his own life for
sure
just not like everyone else's you know
what I mean
yeah but I guess like for you you're no
no no no it's not when you say it like
that like but you are the main character
of everyone's life that you're in
we can say that yeah yeah but Luke isn't
it so are you
thank you you are definitely like main
character you're like do you have
Charisma like you walk into a room and
like the room changes you know what I
mean oh my God thank you I need to bring
up Luke more if these are the
compliments yeah I guess I could see I
could see how like you saying that that
what I said was me and I could see how
that's definitely true
um what I was saying is just like I
really honestly don't know what I was
saying and now I feel like a bully I
think I get what I I get what you're
saying more so
okay but like in the movie of Luke's
life where he is the main character as
you've stated like when will it be his
turn and what does his turn even look
like okay so I feel like it's been his
turn like he got on the show people
really like him he's very handsome I
think he was like you know trying to
become an actor before now he probably
makes a good living he gets a lot of
girls I think Luke is fine
you think it looks fine yeah I think
Luke is like totally [ __ ] totally
fine okay okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story oh my God already yeah but yeah
it's some twists
I'm ready for our fifth and final story
go dogs
go dogs go
it is some Twisted [ __ ] news Bravo
adjacent because uh at the end of last
week Randall Emmett's ex-wife Amber
Childers claimed that the FBI is
investigating Randall for pedophilia
Amber Childers wait
did we report on Friday about Lisa Rinna
yeah oh okay I don't remember sorry
continue I thought that was the story it
wasn't very memorable other than to say
yeah remember we talked about ding dong
what could it mean we should be yeah
yeah thank you
um Amber Childers claimed in a court
filing that the FBI is investigating her
ex-husband Randall Emmett for suspected
child exploitation and pedophilia also
Randall Emmett is the former partner of
Lala Kent who is our Queen on Vanderpump
Rules um mother of ocean Childers who
shares two minor children producer
producer
a Hollywood producer yes Childers who
shares two minor children with Emmett
made the explosive allegation and
assigned declaration she submitted
submitted as part of a domestic violence
restraining order request filed in the
LA Superior Court in late December in
the court documents obtained by Page Six
the actress alleged that the movie
producer is quote being investigated by
the FBI for suspected child exploitation
and or pedophilia
Emmett by the way Randall has denied the
allegation telling page six I'm not
being investigated by the FBI nor anyone
else and the notion that I am is beyond
absurd he said anyone can say whatever
they want in a pleading that doesn't
make it true there are zero evidence
that I'm being investigated for anything
and we will still share 50 50 custody of
our children I am shocked and in utter
disbelief that Amber would even hint at
something so disgusting and untrue and
then he also posted a video to his
Instagram where he slams these quote
lies as well at this point the lies have
been stretched so far we spent today
getting confirmation because we knew
there was no truthfulness to any of this
that the FBI has never been
investigating me and isn't investigating
me because there's nothing to
investigate
so that's his size I mean well the thing
the good thing about this is like it's
not he said she said like either there's
an FBI investigation or there ain't so
we'll just have to wait and see what the
verdict of that is because that's it's a
huge huge allegation it's a huge
allegation and I
often like you know divorces can be
messy and people say stuff and I feel
like typically I would be like
we kind of have to wait and see like you
can't just like slander you're innocent
until you're proven guilty but like
Randall is a liar like he lied to us he
lied to Lala like he's yeah so I'm
inclined to disbelieve him also people
have been referencing the fact that over
the last year since Lala left him like
she's been alluding to stuff about
Randall that she said that is so
disgusting so depraved she can't even
say like we know some of the stuff that
he did during their relationship and
like some of the lies you know the brown
fake diamond ring that she was wearing
for two years
um but then she was also saying that
there's more that she found out that
it's just like so awful so gross and
people are now thinking that this might
be that so it kind of seems like
there's a trail here it tracks a little
bit it's it doesn't seem like it's so
inconceivable but yes you are innocent
until proven guilty and I guess
technically anyone can plead anything
but to write it in a sworn statement in
a Judicial document seems like kind of
crazy if it's not true
I also am curious about the relationship
between Amber and Lala do we know it's
good obviously at first it's good
it's good they got they started getting
along when Lala was still with Randall
yeah and I think now that Lala's yeah
Lala's not with him like I think they
have a good relationship I think Lala
has like so much respect for her and I
think everything's fine between the two
of them
okay good
yeah but what's Twisted is like so say
their FBI is investigating Randall he
still has that custody of his daughters
he has three daughters between the two
women and so that's [ __ ] weird if
these allegations are true
right
um and how do we just find out if
they're true I feel like can the FBI
release a statement I'm curious I know
the FBI like really should weigh in but
they won't do that
well
um
hopefully it's not true but if it is
like that's actually disgusting and vile
and he deserves jail so we'll wait and
see
and perhaps he will get jail once the
investigation is concluded
um those were the past five you
certainly needed to know I would argue
most of them
um and that was our first La show like
how did you feel
I felt good I'm really excited that
you're in La bring some La energy which
we could always use considering like we
are a podcast we're influencers so like
we are inherently thirsty and we need
some of that la
energy
and you know what we always say
we do always say it
so we've got more episodes coming out
this week I'm recording two interviews
while I'm here just trying to like
do the most with my time here you know
can't wait for these interviews
interviews so that's our show we're
gonna rap correct anything else you want
to chit chat about girl from no that is
all from me I will see you tomorrow for
another Hollywood episode where you've
gotten Hollywood now so you really can't
even talk to us
oh wait Jackie do you hear that you
should pick up your phone Hollywood is
calling
my phone is in use but I'll just text
back that I'll call them later
send to voicemail thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube if you're watching us on YouTube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so on Spotify iTunes Stitch
our public radio I already castbox all
the places where we listen to podcast
find us the toast leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
wickedly talented we are hope you guys
have an incredib Monday we'll see you
tomorrow for Tuesday's episode until
then arrivederci
until then goodbye love you
Jackie no arrivederci
au revoir
yes
I like that bye guys we're so
International we got that from Babel you
guys
100 co-host
code thirst